call of duty's special weapons class has
always been a fun way to spice up the
old loadout
everything from ballistic knives to home
improvement tools these are the weapons
of choice
used for fun and of course to annoy
others if you love talking call of duty
like we do
subscribe to gamespot to enjoy more
videos just like this one
let's begin kicking off our list is the
flamethrower from call of duty world at
war
unlocked at level 65 the flamethrower is
a sure
fire wait nope i'm going to start that
over the m2 flamethrower is a gratuitous
close quarters weapon while it's not an
instant kill the flames can linger and
cause additional damage
the fire also works like a smoke screen
making it harder for enemies to see you
also thanks to its spread it's a great
weapon to have when you find a group of
unsuspecting enemies
did you know that the world record for
noctur owned toten was achieved using
the flamethrower
krupps here made it over 5 000 rounds
with no cheats or hacks
just the flamethrower before we go any
further i want to mention the d13 sector
and the diy 11 renovator from black ops
3.
simply put as weapons these kind of
stink
but i wanted to at least mention them
because they're pretty dang silly and i
think goofy guns like this can be
celebrated
if you didn't know black ops 3 launched
some dlc guns that were basically power
tools
the d13 sector is a handheld circular
saw
and the renovator is a nail gun
unfortunately they're weird and
underpowered and they were locked behind
loot crates so not everyone was able to
experience them
while they're nowhere near the top of
our list on performance alone i felt it
necessary to at least
acknowledge these bad boys i like when
cod gets a little wild
next up we have the valkyrie rockets
from black ops 1. this special weapon
was made available after going on a 7
kill streak or via care package
unlike other launchers valkyrie rockets
are guided by the player
once they're fired picture the nikita
cruise missiles from metal gear solid
without the stealth with a generous
timer and even a boost function
you could launch one of these missiles
at other players or enemy aircraft
you can even launch it vertically and
use it like a predator missile from
modern warfare
the only problem with these is that they
have to be air delivered to you and you
can't just pull them out of your pocket
like mary poppins would
[Music]
i have to talk about this one because
it's considered a special weapon in
three call of duty titles so
here we go the riot shield otherwise
known as the assault shield is a
portable
bulletproof barrier that can deflect
most lethal equipment
such as grenades and claymores it could
also be used in combat
okay i'll stop as we know the riot
shield can be very polarizing
you either love it or hate it but you
can't deny that it works
in fact i think the problem is that it
works too well
you see i'm getting picked on just by
using it when you come across someone
using it
you can either chuck your thermite and
pray for the best or run away like this
guy
it's an added layer of frustration when
you're just trying to survive a game of
team deathmatch or worse
warzone but it has its uses in other
game modes like search and destroy and
domination
and of course if you need those throwing
knife kills the riot shield is your best
friend
unless you're me
the minigun or as black ops likes to
call it the death machine
is a massive fully auto rotary gun with
a super high rate of fire
it's loud destructive and can kill you
in an instant
it's basically the chopper gunner
without the chopper and
the weapon of choice for juggernauts
remember the scene in resident evil 2
where nemesis
kills like a dozen stars members or when
the rock helps take down a helicopter in
fast and furious 7
that's how it feels to wield the minigun
unless when you know
you get killed before you're able to
fire a single bullet
i like the other way better
why why was i programmed to feel pain
the war machine is the older brother to
the noob tube it's refined
stylish and deadly it grew up and now
carries six grenades instead of only two
with the war machine you can take your
time and tactically plan your shots
or if you're like me you can spam them
all at once you're bound to hit someone
or even blow up a car or red barrel
when i get killed by a noob tube i get
angry when i get killed by a war machine
i blame myself like an adult
and think of what i could have done
differently this is my fault and while
it's not the most poised special weapon
the war machine is always a blast to use
next we have the um excuse me the m202
flash aka the grim
reaper was only featured in black ops 1.
the sole way to get one is through a
care package
and it's not very common but when you do
manage to snag one
it's a real treat so don't blow it like
i did
the grim reaper is a four barrel
semi-auto rocket launcher
most rocket launchers without lock-on
features have an incredibly high recoil
like the rpg
however with the grim reaper recoil is
not an issue you can fire all four of
your rockets back to back
each one of them doing 150 damage this
was the same badass launcher seen in
commando wielded by none other than
arnold schwarzenegger
it was so cool that they made a cell
phone case and arnold
has that case and you can take this
picture of him holding his case and make
your own
phone case or you can choose to ignore
me altogether
it'd be cool to see the grim reaper
return but so far no luck
thanks for nothing black ops cold war
now we're talking the ballistic knife
sounds like something right out of a
bond film
it's a spring-loaded knife with a blade
that you can eject from the handle
it of course also doubles as a melee
weapon that works faster than your
standard knife
in black ops 1 the ballistic knife does
250 damage when fired
which is a major flex seeing as you only
have 100 health that's like killing your
enemy two and a half times
why would they do that because it's
badass but hey if you want to hear more
about the ballistic knife and its real
world use
you gotta check out our expert reacts
episode where our friend and gun guru
jonathan ferguson breaks it all down
the only way you can load this is by
pressing it
into a wall or the ground or i don't
know the corpses of your enemies or
something
[Music]
before we reveal our number one pick
we've got a quick honorable mention to
make for the venom x and call of duty
ghosts
it's an acid spewing launcher from
ghost's extinction mode
this weapon didn't make the list because
it's more of an easter egg than a usable
weapon
at least in multiplayer it's main
purpose of course is blast and aliens
but it was nice to see in multiplayer it
even returned as a regular launcher in
call of duty infinite warfare
where it remained basically unchanged it
could have used some buffs to be taken
seriously outside of extinction
but an aim for effort for including it
at all
the crossbow the holy grail of spy
weapons
this fan favorite weapon got its start
in the first black ops title
it was used in memorable missions like
wmd and executive order but was
popularized further with its use in
multiplayer modes
in high-stakes game modes like wager
match and gun game the crossbow was
always fun to use
even with its drawbacks like slow reload
time and small reserve of arrows
the crossbow continued to make
appearances in several other call of
duty titles as late as 2019's modern
warfare
where it can be kitted out with just
about anything but even without all the
bells and whistles the crossbow is a fun
and unique weapon that definitely hits
the term special
let me know which special weapon is your
favorite and if you want to see more
call of duty videos check out this
playlist with more ranked videos
expert reacts and more thanks for
watching
[Music]
you